AND HE'LL START AWAY WITH IT AND
THE LINEUP A LITTLE BIT.
JFORMER
CANADIEN BENN.CENTREMAN, ZUK IT
WILD BACK WITH IT
PENGUIN GOES BEHIND THE NET.
ERICKSONRTY IS TRUSTING YOU TO
PLAY DEFENSE AGAINST ONE O ZUCC
SUZU
>> Dan: SUZUKI WITH FIVE POINTS
.
NO STICK FOR DAUPHIN.
SO THE CANADIENS COULD BE IN  T
ONE THAT BROKE -- HE TAKES OFF.
WAT
THERE'S A CHANCE AND A SWING AND
A MIS'S STILL ROOM FOR
A GUY THAT LIKESPEDED VIEW OF
THAT.OURAY USED TO LOVE TO
DO THAT.
>> Dan: HE'S THE LAST GUY YOU
WOULD WANT TO S
WITH THE GLOVE AS PITLICK TRYING
TO GET HIS FIRST AS A C
SKATE THROUGH IT, AND P
MOMENT.
THEY'RE HANGING OUT A LOT AS YOU
WOULD EXPECT AND THE S.
FIALA, BRODIN TO,
STOPPED THERE BY
NOBODY REALLY GETS ON HIM.
HEHIS FIRST AS A CANADIEN AND
WE'RE TIED AT ONE! GAUDREAU IN T
GET TAKEN AWAY.
YOU CAN SEE BY HIS F
REVIEW, IT WAS DETERMINED THAT .
DVORAK SHOOTS, NOT MUCH OF AN
SHOOTOUT IN MONTREAL.
GING AND DOING
ALL OF IT RIGHT AROUN OFFENSE.
BUT STILL RIGHT IN IT,
OBVIOUSLY, 1-NOTHING AS PERIOD
THREE SBACKBOARDS, PUT IT IN
AND IT'S 2-NOTHING MINNESOTA. W
RECOGNIZE IT.
CAREY GETS A LITTLE OUT OF
SORTS.
YOU C
FIALA, BOLDY AND...
CAUFIELD RIGHT IN AND A  SAVE!
THIS IS CAUFIELD, HE'LL DRAG IT.
THEY'LL GET THE SHOT THEY WANT
AND HERE IT IS, SPURGEON WITH
THE DRIVE AND PLL AND BE
ABLE TO WALK INTO A ONE-TIMER
AND YOU GOT